for today's classic interview continuing
with our Friday conspiracy theories we
had dr. Jim Garrow last week I won't
rehash that this week we are going back
to my October of 2014 interview with
Judith Barry Baker
she had I don't want to spoil it for you
but she had some outrageous ideas about
the assassination of John F Kennedy and
Lee Harvey Oswald and I think I'm only
going to say that and nothing else if
you've not seen this interview and
because our audience has grown so
drastically over the last year this 2014
interview maybe in fact I'm sure that it
is brand new to most in our audience I
will stop here with the introduction and
just tell you this was a very very very
interesting interview and we will dig
into it right now I'm joined today by
Judith very Baker who is the author of
the new book David Ferrie mafia pilot
participant an anti-castro bio weapon
plot and as well as a friend of Lee
Harvey Oswald and key to the JFK
assassination Judith Barry Baker claims
to be the former lover of Kennedy
assassin Lee Harvey Oswald this is such
an incredible story miss Baker I'm
thrilled to have you on let's start at
the beginning how did you meet Lee
Harvey Oswald
Oh Lee was sent briefly he was sent when
I arrived in New Orleans and I was only
19 I arrived early for us an assignment
that turned out to be CIA sponsored
project to kill Castro
I was very anti Castro but I had been
trained to handle sv40 monkey virus and
other dangerous parts components of
cancer in cancer research and I was
alone and he was sent to protect me and
make sure I would be safe until the
doctors returned they were in South
America when I came so let's start there
because there's there's a lot there as
my audience can obviously tell to look
at so you were working for the CIA at
the time well I didn't know it of course
they only tell you what they have to
tell you but eventually of course I did
understand because Lee and I developed a
relationship that turned into a love
affair and I can assure you that Lee
was framed it did not kill Kennedy I
mean this is an obsolete thing the
Warren Commission has put together but
we have let's not skip ahead oh let's
not skip ahead let's go piece by piece I
don't want my audience to miss a second
of this so what was the project that you
were working on with regard to Castro
all right we know no the CIA and mafia
work together to try to kill Castro they
had tried everything now this was a
covert attempt to do use it sir because
Fidel Castro smoked cigars and we had we
knew that we could get if we could get
lung cancer cells injected into him of a
certain kind that they've been working
on that he would probably die from it
so this is a sort of bio weapon correct
yes and that was 50 years ago imagine
what we have today now I'm curious why
would the CIA at that time need to
develop something as complex as
injecting lung cancer cells when they
already had so many poisons that could
have killed Castro Ritter Lorenz for
example they gave her poison pills you
hid them in cold cream and they
dissolved other people would be
connected to that but he was getting
like EPT shots and things and nobody
could ever trace if it was done
correctly that he was really getting
cancer cells instead so you meet Lee
Harvey Oswald and he reveals to you he's
been sent to protect you talk about that
what was he sent to protect you from
well from Castro spies the the whole
project was in New Orleans and that's a
point you know that's a point of entry
and many Cubans were coming in who knew
we didn't know whether there were spies
or not because what they were also
training insurgents there to try and
reinvent and all that's in the book and
by the way it's all documented I have
witnesses also as to my relationship
that are on film and tape about the fact
that we had a relationship let's go
let's go step by step again not to get
too far ahead of ourselves
here's just an innocent question that I
hope you have the answer to if you
didn't even know you were working for
the CIA how would it be that you needed
to be protected from foreign elements
that knew
were working fast very that's an
excellent question well even though I
didn't we had there was penetration into
the CIA from a lot of Cubans because CIA
was working with them and to determine
who's who was on castro side it's not
that easy okay so they're you know how
did you how did your relationship with
Lee Harvey Oswald develop well it it's
they're a series of circumstances
basically we both had very unhappy
marriages my my former husband he
married me one day and the next day he
was gone I mean he didn't tell me where
he even went for weeks at a time it
really hurt my feelings and as for Lee
he had to marry his wife when he was in
the USSR so he wouldn't get deported so
it wasn't like a marriage made in heaven
and who publicly would know about your
relationship with Lee Harvey Oswald well
we have Anna Lewis and others we have
the Charles Thomas family we have Mack
McCullough these are witnesses who have
gone on tape and film verifying that
Tommy with Lee and then you kissing me
and things you know well but let's not
let's I want to stay because this is
such a big issue
right I want to stay as close to the
facts as I know them and then you can
correct me where I'm wrong
Anna Lewis who's the former wife of
David Lewis has confirmed that she saw
you on a couple of dates with Lee Harvey
Oswald and you did you have but hold on
let me get the question out you'll have
plenty of time to respond and that you
did both work together but Anna Lewis
has not stated anything in terms of any
kind of a romantic relationship it's
correct in her film that's on YouTube it
says I was his mistress now I think that
pretty much confirms the relationship
Anna Lewis has claimed that you say
thank you sir
she has asserted that that was your
claim though she had no sir it's in a
way it's not a claim Lee and I we have a
complete relationship that you can
establish from actually right from at
least as early as May 9th when we were
both hired by a tiny company the same
day one week later we are moved together
it's all in the records official records
with all due respect though being hired
by the same company does not prove that
there's any kind of affair even by our
check stubs which I kept all fifty years
now
and I know that doesn't that only
doesn't that only prove that you were
both being paid by the same company let
me just give you an example well I want
but miss Baker my objective is to
present the audience with the data my
audience knows that my check stub and my
producers come from the same small
company that would not of course prove
that I'm in any kind of relationship
with my producer where are you hired the
same day and where and when if he got
fired would you be fired the same day I
don't know I guess we'd have to wait and
see if that happens of course it's
speculative so let's go to the moment of
the assassination right talk to us about
that day what was that like well I was I
had been sent out of the project because
I had been actually I had been kicked
out because I had epical objections to
using prisoners who were volunteers and
they were going to be injected with us
and if it worked it would kill them and
because I objected they sent me back to
Florida it really saved my life
but Lee and I stayed in contact I talked
to him via phone and we have some kinds
of records to help substantiate that
what kind of records well the the Warren
Commission noticed that a woman with no
accent called the Texas schoolbook
depository and as for the janitor now
Lee was not a janitor he was a clerk
there but that was a the way that I
contacted him the first two initials of
my name are Judith Anne and that's what
I used and the the name of janitor is
for me trying to find somebody else in
working position so he knew it was me
and called me back and we have a lot of
other material that I have inside
information and now has been
substantiate is for example I told
people in 1999 that Lee had saved
Kennedy's life he believed he did and
now we have Abraham Bolden that came out
and said that's true Lee Oswald is Lee
is the one who called the FBI in Chicago
at save Kennedy's life well no listen I
mean here's the thing miss Baker
I do you do you see why from the point
of view of an
audience when you say all of this has
been substantiated but there is no hold
on but you don't provide substantiation
and such independent substantiation
doesn't exist the documents which i have
in a 538 page book the documents are
there I understand that I'm merely I'm
merely trying to have just a
conversation with you which is I would
love it if you would give me your
opinion as to whether you understand why
people for decades have been so
skeptical of your your claims do you
understand that I haven't made these
claims sir what you call claims for
decades I spoke out for the first time
in 1999 after a silence of 35 years and
it's over three decades right no sir
that's not over three decades that's one
year in 1999 and we are now at 2014 okay
I apologize if my if my semantics were
wrong but over a period that that
spanned three different decades a period
that spans three days I have no more
problem sir except with maybe somebody
in New York when I claim that I knew Lee
Oswald what we were working on that
that's why in the last two years I
haven't had opposition but that's not
true miss Baker with all due respect
it's not true to say you've had no
opposition there are sir I'm talking
about in rape most of the interviews
I've had the opposition is is old it
comes from the same people all the way
back to 99 who never met me I'm sensing
that you're getting very defensive but
I'm merely asking basic questions you
have and you say I have you you're
talking about that I don't have
documentation I all I'm saying miss
Baker is that an assertion is not
evidence that the assertion book the
book is called me and Lee and the other
book is David Ferrie mafia pilot you can
get them from trying day publisher so
you can go to amazon.com they'll create
the reviews you know miss Baker I was
really hoping to be able to have more of
level discussion okay about why these
these claims are so heavily contested
it's not bears that's the thing we
disagree about that miss Baker with all
due respect miss Baker one group only
people have never met me some and one of
them is led by a man whose book was
cancelled because of my book did you
ever meet John F Kennedy what has that
to do with what we're talking about have
you what the reason it matters is you're
saying anyone who hasn't met you can't
reasonably criticize or know what is or
is not true about your life but you make
claims about the assassination of
Kennedy a man whom you've never met
people these people the book before it
was even published sir before they knew
how to spell my name properly they put
it with an I they were attacking me they
never met me and they produce silly
things like I they said I only have one
paycheck or that I only newly for 11
weeks things like that that you can read
they're not true it but I've not said
those things I've not said those things
no you haven't but you have said that I
have a lot of opposition sir I'm going
to 31 cities this is being financed by
people who have read the book they from
plane ticket to plane tickets from hotel
to hotel and I'm reaching the people I
love liaise along with all my heart all
right well you know I I hoped we could
have a different sort of discussion I
apologize that it went in this direction
but I'll tell you what I encourage the
audience to do as you say check out the
book and see if it resonates with you
and and and go from there so I do thank
you for being on Miss Baker we've been
speaking with Judith very bail exactly
how I feel
thank you so much god bless